anger and frustration in the Tunisian
capital
these demonstrators are protesting
against Monday's constitutional
referendum which they say would give
president Kai Saeed too much power amen
we will boycott this referendum we are
determined to struggle against the
absolute autocracy until Tunisia regains
its natural institutional and Democratic
status
critics accuse Saeed of trying to rule
by decree saying his proposed changes
amount to a coup against the
Constitution
since last July the president has sacked
dozens of Judges suspended Parliament
and assumed executive power maintaining
he was ending years of political chaos
I call on you great people of Tunisia to
vote Yes so that the course of the
Revolution can be correct
I was one of the success stories of the
Arab Spring a sweeping movement of
uprisings across the Middle East Africa
that top holds several dictators
but analysts say president saeed's
reforms would push the nation back
towards a system reminiscent of one
before the 2011 Revolution
they worry the new constitution will
completely dismantle democracy there's
nothing that can be done to hold the
present accountable other than waiting
for the end of the five-year term
there's no Authority no other
institution in the state that can
control him there's no mechanism to hold
him accountable there's simply nothing
that can be done
despite regular domestic and
international condemnation Saeed seems
determined to establish a centralized
political system one where the president
Reigns Supreme
turnout for the referendum is expected
to be low with many people saying the
vote won't be free or Fair
Saeed has banned rival political
advertising and told International
election observers they're not welcome
but no matter the outcome critics say
Tunisia has a long way to go to return
to the path of democracy
Jillian wolf Al Jazeera